hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast mechanisms of anti microbial
bio conversion by an environmental and
host associated bacteria presented by
dr. Terrence Kraus a pathology and
immunology post doctoral scholar in the
dantas lab at Washington University in
st. Louis
I'm dr. Susie Valdes of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during this presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have any trouble hearing or see
presentation just click on ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits so click on that
continuing education credits tab located
on the top right corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process for obtaining those credits
without further ado let me welcome our
presenter please join me dr. Terrence
Crofts I will now turn the presentation
over to him welcome sir thank you for
that introduction and thank you to
elaborate and Susie and Tiffany for how
they get all this together like he said
I'm representing work done by the Thomas
Thomas plan when I was a postdoctoral
scholar there Washington University in
San Luis and I changed my title for my
talk today a little bit to discovery and
characterization of antibiotic
resistance and catabolism mechanisms and
so probably what I'm gonna be talking
about is various ideas about the ecology
of antibiotics before I get into
I want to start by talking about why
antibiotics are important and so that
doesn't really need to be stem but I
think it's worth going over anyways how
transformational antibiotics really have
been and so the example that I'm showing
you right now is this graph showing the
mortality rates for a hundred thousand
people across the first two-thirds of
the 20th century and what's really
notable is that if you look at the trend
lines this mortality is decreasing over
time but there's a peculiar steepening
of that decline shown this box kind of
sensor from 1940 and what's driving that
increase our decrease in mortality rate
is the introduction of antibiotics to
treat tuberculosis pneumonia and other
bacterial infections as a suite drives
home the point that antibiotics are an
integral part of modern medicine and
this is kind of looking at that history
of antibiotics is a new graph this graph
is showing is in lieu of the years when
first in class antibiotics were reduced
and in red when resistances for some
shirts in the clinic and what I was
taking away from this graph are two
major points the first being that most
of the antibiotics that we do on the
love were discovered his first in class
compounds over 50 years ago this
so-called golden age of s bionics a
second major points to get from this
graph is that in most cases just a few
years after their introduces the clinic
doctors were able to observe the
evolution of antibiotic resistance and
bacterial infections shown in red so
it's kind of across this points that
antibiotics have been very important to
medicine but they are steadily losing
ground against as about resistance and
so that's not why I wants to preempt
this idea and ironic because you're the
ecology events products and this is kind
of
a way of talking about a few different
points the first one is that a lot of
antibiotics we use in medicine are
actually natural products or derived
from natural products that it is
microorganisms and often bacteria in the
environment the soil for example are the
producers of these and I'm showing those
here is these little spiky red balls but
that's not the end of the story of
antibiotics of course once they're in
the environment they're there as a way
for bacteria to compete against their
neighbors and so oftentimes their
neighbors will develop antibiotic
resistant strategies to protect
themselves from these otherwise
antibacterial molecules and so he's
talking in a lot about the second of
those points and then about half the
last half of my talk is going to be
about this third component of this
ecology of antibiotics which is sort of
the backend of things what happens to
these antibiotics in the environment can
they just sit there or they degrade it
and it turns out there are bacteria that
are able to actually consume antibiotics
and so I'm gonna be presenting on my
research of studying the enzymes and
mechanisms and pathways that bacteria
use to catabolized antibiotics first
time we talking more about resistance
and reason for that is that resistance
is an important part of the story but
it's also a large problem by itself so
in the last few years we've been able to
tally the number of deaths resulting
from antibiotic resistant infections and
years before this antibiotics was
working through these infections and
save lives but now more people are dying
because the bacteria are resistant to
the antibiotics that are used in
medicine and it's estimated by some that
in the next coming decades the annual
global death toll due to resistant
infections could rise as high as 10
million people now it's not just the
lives lost it's also about straining the
medical system and hurting economies the
exams I vomit resistant infections are
much more costly and time consuming to
treat even if there's a good
yeah and so compounding this rise and
resistance is this decline in the last
decade especially the last few years in
development of new major classes of
antibiotics so like I said earlier the
Golden Age of antibiotics most of these
compounds were first discovered was
fifty years ago
and while resistance has been increasing
a market for new antibiotics has not
been very good and so a lot of major
biopharmaceutical companies have been
exceeding the antibiotic discovery arena
and I think in the past two years or so
actually another three big players have
shuttered their natural products of
divisions or antibiotic divisions and so
it's kind of this problem that's
increasing and so it's worth talking
about where was distance Santa boxes
coming from it's not just rising out
they may or it needs to come from genes
that exist somewhere and one of the
major hypotheses for where as about
persistence arises at least originally
this thing called the producer
hypothesis and so this hypothesis posits
is that antibiotic resistance
originates from those bacteria that are
the original producers of antibiotics
and that makes sense because you expect
that as the bacteria is producing an
antibacterial compound it would need to
take some steps to protect itself and so
a lot of these producers actually encode
resistant chains that protect the host
from the extra Ballack that's making
that pump it out and sort of failsafe a
lot of them also have antibiotic
degrading or an antibiotic and modifying
enzymes to detoxify any compound that
accidentally fails to excrete and so
this makes a lot of sense a lot of the
clinically you sense ballets that have
developed resistance and the resistance
the belt against them originated from
soil bacteria and if you look at sort of
the history of these genes it's been
estimated that the genes for synthesis
and resistance antibiotics are
have been around for a long time
[Music]
and so there's the mice experiments that
kind of support this so where these is a
great paper from the right lab where
they essentially took advantage of the
fact that permafrost which has been
frozen for tens of thousands of years
provides sort of a history lesson of
each era where the ice or the permafrost
was frozen and so what they did in this
paper was they dug down till their
permafrost that correspond in roughly
230 thousand years is the past
extracting DNA and then sequence that
DNA in order to look for the presence of
antibiotic resistance genes and despite
this being tens of thousands of years
prior to the industrial use that's
without expert than their discovery
they're able to find genes that living
code resistance to it lacks antibiotics
like penicillin and just lightening them
so by resistance chains and resistance
genes to quite compact life such as
pinky mice and so even before humans
were using these a large scale bacteria
have already very thoroughly discovered
ways to protect themselves and so this
is an thematic resistance already in the
environment but that's not to say that
humans aren't having their own impact as
well so this third paper that I'm
showing not at all Howry also look at
soil samples clicked over the past
century and then quantify the abundance
of different antibiotic resistance genes
over time and so they saw those
agreements that's before antibiotics
were produced you're able to find these
resistance change from the environment
but what's very notable and somewhat
frightening in a stack over time as
humans began using as we Alex on a more
industrial scale both medically and in
agriculture you see a continent rise the
abundance of these different about
resistance genes really demonstrating
battements halves plenty for this in the
environment and so there's the question
of how much does this matter and the
Meneses amount because mutants are acts
with the environment a lot so this is
just
my speakers chilly a lot of different
routes by which is why like resistance
genes rant about resistant bacteria can
travel between different environments so
a great example is we use a lot of
mathematics and agriculture for things
like livestock so antibiotics resistance
or bacteria can of course tell them that
livestock to humans directly through
farm handlers or indirectly through the
food that we consume or it can also go
directly to the environment either from
agricultural runoff through the manure
and in a sense pollute the environment
with those as balanced those resistance
chains well those was just a bacteria
and those can come back into contact
with humans through a variety of means
so then the question is do we actually
observe a lot of transfer across
environments and previous work by the
novice lab summarize this review figure
from of my papers really supports that
concept and so what was I was being
shown here is a schematic of a static
resistance genes and associated genes
that were pulled from either a village
in El Salvador or a terrier urban slum
in Peru that was notable about this is
that that highlighted pink region is
showing that the same 10:1 beta
lactamase is present across a variety of
different environments when I say the
same gene I mean that it has something
close to my her percent because type
identity across all these environments
you can actually track this gene being
passed from bacterias bacteria through
human waste military or emily's into
wastewater treatment as a wastewater
treatment effluent is you can see that
these genes
already is shared around which shows
just how important it is to consider
resistance in the environment and what
has balanced for doing in the
environment so on one slide sacrifice
as well results is this concept that is
hard to study antibiotic about
resistance and other functions of the
soil microbiome because of this concept
called the great place counts anomaly
and some of this idea of describes is
this idea that if you took a slow sample
and tries to grow bacteria ferment you
might get something like this image of a
petri dish however you see alongside
bacterial colonies and it appears to be
relatively diverse you can see a lot of
red colors at size morphologies but if
you were to take that same sample of
soil and look at it under microscope you
might instead see something like tenfold
or a hundredfold rare diversity because
something like 99% of bacteria from the
soil are not able to grow very easily in
the laboratory so if you want to study
antibiotic resistance in the soil it's
necessary to use tools that don't rely
solely on culturing and so what the
Duncans lab does and what the other
allows to this area is use this method
called functional metagenomics which on
this fry basically we start with a
sample of a microbiome that we wants to
investigate so for example a pile of
soil but can also be a fecal sample for
a chemical biota or other samples that
have indeed bacteria at them what we do
is we extract the genomic DNA from all
the bacteria in that sample to get a
manageable maintaining sample and
because the dominus lab was interested
in studying sonic resistance what we do
is we take that DNA sample and shear it
down to the size of an atomic resistance
gene or a few g and so two thousand to
five thousand base pairs and size and
then clone that and mass into an
expression plasmid
we can then take that expression plasmid
that library plasmids and transformed
them into a library of e.coli and this
when we get this library coli that
encodes often somewhere around the given
base or more environmentally
so can encompass millions of millions of
genes now what we do to pull out the
genes that were interested in is we take
that minor e coli and we played it onto
our plates containing some sort of
selective pressure so if we're looking
for antibiotic resistance these might be
on their place that contain penicillin
for example and penicillin is normally
able to kill e.coli so any colonies that
form on this penicillin plate must
therefore contain ecoli that is
expressing a penicillin resistance chain
from the environmental DNA on that
plasmid and we can do is we can take
these colonies we can amplify the
plasmid DNA outs whose the inflammation
chain reaction and then using
next-generation sequencing to read all
those inserts that might not want to
contain and after assembling and
annotating those worries we're also able
to see what resistance genes are in that
environment so this case that we
selected on penicillin we'd like we see
a lot of the elastic mixes so the
students in the dominant thumb before
our eyes had done experiment like this
before
this Forsberg a tall paper what he did
was he took soil samples and analyze it
for the resistance chains to it'll
actives tetracyclines
and Fenna calls and aminoglycoside
antibiotics we've done was that the soil
contains multitude and a high diversity
of antibiotic resistance chains
especially for the alack tenza
tetracyclines in this case has some
interesting patterns that we observed
that this was that for middle atoms and
then pinnacles and immuno clankenspy
dense products preferred mechanism with
soil resistance is through a static
modification or degradation and in
contrast resistance adjusts to
tetracycline was mostly mediated by e
flux pumps so this shows that the soil
contains multitude of extra resistance
genes does that mean that all these
shoes are going to end up in hospitals
and be a problem for us another funny
people is that that's probably not going
to be the case
this is a little bit of a shitty figure
so I'll take my time to explain it but
it's basically trying to measure you
likelihood of a resistance gene
spreading from relatively harmless soil
bacteria into a pathogenic bacteria so
what's measured here is how far how many
nucleotides you have to essentially walk
away from a resistance chain BC of DNA
before you went into a gene that's
associated with horizontal gene transfer
so transposon or the origin of
replication for a plasmid oh you can see
when you compare soil bacteria versus
pathogen bacteria and their genomes and
their resistance genes is that you don't
have to walk nearly as far on a pathogen
genome from an in stop resistance gene
before you run into one of these
immobilization elements I've compared to
a soil that's here now really implies
that these resistance genes in the soil
a relative named locked in place and are
not as likely to be spread especially
compared to the likelihood of pathogens
in clinical settings bringing their
resistance genes now that's the case at
large but there's no specific examples
that are very different so that was all
functional metagenomics we're kind of
avoid a culture Inc but if instead you
look at the cultural comfortable
component of the soil we get a slightly
different picture this is again another
paper by Forsberg also got some dantas
where they essentially took SLO bacteria
and cultured them in the presence of
very high concentrations of antibiotics
so something on the order of one made
per mil which is a very high
concentration considering we usually use
tenfold less than that or even lower
concentrations when we are selecting for
resistance in bacteria so this is any
bacteria that grows are going to be
highly resistant what they found was
that most of the bacteria that
come out of this selection the soil are
Prodi bacteria and many of them are
rather than to or actually our close
relatives sucking the pathogens and so
going back to the producer at offices i
mentioned earlier if you look at the
number of antibiotics that those
bacterias producers of antibiotics are
resistant to there were often resistant
to multiple passes but on average from
like seven or eight and this is a nice
distribution i here in the lower left
corner where there aren't very many
strains that have an extremely high
number of chiefs they're resistant to
now that's in contrast this graph of the
lore by corner in which we're looking at
the number of s gothics that's these
multi drug-resistant soil soil pretty
bacteria are resistant to and so most of
them are resistant to over 15 and a
plurality of them are resistant to
nearly 20 different classes of
antibiotics so this is really showing
that this these are somewhat worrisome
bacteria and not only that if you look
at at the mobility of these resistance
genes can be Beshear's of the bacteria
it looks like these proteobacteria a lot
more reminiscent of the pathogens and
that was soil bacterium that earlier
figure and then I I mean if you look at
the resistant shoes that come out I
showed him this brown anything that was
shaded gray is another example of a gene
that has found across different
bacterial strains and different
bacterial species that have something
like other percent this identity which
is highly suggestive of horizontal gene
transfer as you can see that a lot of
these multi drug-resistant highly
resistant Proteobacteria have multiple
different and sped up resistance genes
shown in red as well as having multiple
mobility elements shown in green nearby
but these are found across a variety of
different pathogens as well as these not
pathogenic bacteria so this is really
see that these are bacteria that are
worth keeping an eye on and so I'm gonna
use that to actually switch into this
second half of my talk because it
happens that these bacteria have another
really interesting phenotypes and that
is some of these highly antibiotic
resistant bacteria are not will be able
to avoid being killed by antibiotics
they're also actually able to use those
antibiotics as a sole carbon source it's
nicest thing about this talk where these
are the antibiotic eating bacteria so
this is another representation of the
bacteria that Galton dontist pulled out
of the soil that are able to catalyze
antibiotics and as you can see that is
f1 f2 f3 p1 these are all different
strains of slow bacteria and here on
this graph blue indicates that they're
able to grow using that given
antibiotics sold from source and red
indicates that they cancel early if
strained about this is that most of
these antibiotics are catalyzed '''l by
most of these bacteria and most of these
bacteria can grow on most of these
antibiotics and in particular I want to
point out for now right in the middle is
penicillin G which is the penicillin
that's associated with Fleming first
major that's when bionics discovered
it's actually able to support the growth
of all these trains and so and the
project I'm going to talk about in two
minutes the things that I want to answer
were what are the enzymes and pathways
and mechanisms that some of these soil
bacteria used to pull off this somewhat
astonishing feat that beaten antibiotics
and then also want to answer the
question of are these bacterias or
professional antibiotic eaters or is
this more of a neat trick the bacteria
are able to learn and essentially
evolved into so for the study I focused
on four Proteobacteria that soil
selection terms
ABC
hands about it catabolism bacteria may
be co2 a b c o7 may be sido 8 maybe c 10
and under the antibiotic I focused on
penicillin which is able to support the
growth of all form of this bacterium as
some other interesting interesting
things about consuming on that it's a
natural product that's a graphic so it's
actually produced by soil microorganisms
so the soil bacteria likely have evolved
alongside penicillin for eons we know a
lot about how bacteria resists
penicillin it's mostly through these
it'll activate genes which are enzymes
that catalytically break apart the Galax
arm or head of penicillin so here this
picture where the red atoms meet the
black atoms that's the middle a stem
ring the amide bond there is actually
where it'll atoms hydrolyze that ring
rendering it's non-toxic and finally is
for lumina again penicillin is one of
the first antibiotics that was used
widely in agriculture and medicine and
so not only have so bacteria might be
been exposed to it for millennia over
the past hundred years or so they've
exposed to especially high
concentrations of it so it seems like a
very good candidate for exploring
antibiotic metabolism and so to
something bit about these strains
I know it wants to guess the one who was
worried too much about the phylogeny of
these strains they're pretty bacteria
and they are relatively close relatives
of no human pathogens but I'm not gonna
make a big deal about them and mostly
we'll be referring to the buyer strain
name but just so we can be oriented
there's the phylogenetic tree and maybe
she'll seven which I'll be talking about
a lot it's actually a student monus so
across the bottom here I have four
graphs where we were simply trying to
recapitulate and verify that initial
finding that feeds bacteria can grow
with penicillin is this low carbon
source so these four strains are grown
in middle media where the only carbon
source
available to them is penicillin where
the increasingly blue colors correspond
to increasingly high concentrations
showing here vaccine now that's one gram
per liter carbon source and what I think
is really fun about these graphs is that
the kind of our baptismal we should
expect where we see increasing growth
the more antibiotic we had was not shown
is this actually continues the pattern
up to four grams per liter or to even
eight grams per liter in some cases
penicillin so not only is the penicillin
actually the bacteria is in a sense
making them even stronger so starting
off on this project
my hypothesis I started with is
basically as follows make sure you hear
a kind of cartoony schematic of methyl
biotic and what i hypothesize is what
happened during aesthetic and Taoism is
that the first step is going to be
detoxification of us antibiotic sort of
see the first approach because if the
bacteria is going to kill Maya is not
going to be around to be able to beat
the antibiotic later so that's why I
thought was problem first and I had
publicized that the second step of
antibiotic catabolism would be this
metabolic hydrolytic activity wherein
the carbon source be cleaved off from
the antibiotic and because a lot of
these antibiotics or natural products or
kebap the size that this catabolic
hydrolase enzyme would probably act in a
sort of retro Wow synthetic way that is
and assume for example is made up of
that I'll see the casted and a pair of
amino acids shown here in blue red and
black and so penicillin catabolism
hypothesized would proceed through break
into part that is the two amino acids
and then I'll see a acid so the next
type is to find out what are the enzymes
involved so one of the first things that
we did was we performed whole genome
sequencing at least four and
to tantalize these strains that find out
what sort of functional limits we can
play someone genes they encode and we'll
lose means that really stuck out at us
when we looked at their genomes was that
all four bacteria encode so a high
number of beta lactamase genes either
eight nine or ten they lack nieces with
ABC of seven having the most against
those strongly suggests that in these
traits at least resistance and Casilla
occurs through action Abigail activates
in sign again where that they liked him
Ling it is finalized
Agra screen to produce this non
antibacterial compound called benzyl
pan-islamic acid and that we've been
important later
so that suggests the first step all
about the next steps the women about
finding what the next steps the
catabolism might be was like news me and
transcriptomics and RNA sequencing
specifically so what we did was use with
each ABC strain and grew it in minimal
media where the only carbon source
present would be either penicillin or a
simpler metabolites like glucose or
histidine where we know how that was
have a light enter central metabolism
and what we did was that we simply
compared the ratio of the gene counts of
the gene expression there you grow some
kinda silly compared to glucose for
example to find out what genes are
highly expressed and then find out which
of those are the most difficult and so
that was all I'm showing you here that's
hard to read these numbers but they
represent be full of regulation during
growth on penicillin comparing to growth
on glucose for histidine and was really
striking when we looked at these highly
expressed significantly differentially
expressed genes was that they were
similar across all four antibiotic
catalyzing bacteria so all of them have
an expression of it'll ax mesas and
Ballou
and they all have expression of a whole
suite of genes in green that together
encode this operon called the
phenylacetic acid catabolism Kassadin
source old carbon source which gave us
some what event Elian result and then I
was also really justine was that in each
of these trains they're also highly
expressed significant expressed genes
that were predicted to be annotated as
hydrolases or Hema bases or medial
hydrolases and these are shown in red
and at least in three of these trains
you can see that the Emma dayss that
render laces are synthetic with middle a
kinase that is their brightness that
they'll activate gene which is very
interesting and suggests that they might
be important for the metabolism of beta
lactams - Illin so we've given this we
decided to focus on a VCO 7 and trying
to narrow down and again verify that
these chains aren't important so we did
a few more RNA c experiments so we first
did was we again looked at the relative
of regulation of mistreated genes shown
here across the bottom when maybe CSF
was grown in the presence of penicillin
compared to glucose so just like that
first experiment but we repeated it
again now the same results where these
genes are tenfold 200 to nearly a
thousand fold up regulated during the
growth I can distill and compressor
glucose down the right hand bottom right
corner is the house to be gene R key of
B which you can see is expressed through
the levels across both conditions has
control and what's interesting is when
we instead look at regulation responses
the growth on benzyl an allylic acid we
see some interesting results so the
first thing is in the lower left corner
that first beta lactamase
goes from being highly expressed at a
hundredfold
greater levels in penicillin pretty
glucose down to equals freshmen in Ben's
open a stochastic compared to glucose
which kind of makes sense that that's
the main goal activates that is being
used to resist penicillin because we're
feeding benzoic acid now that's a lot of
an antibiotic it doesn't even have a
penal action ring so there's no reason
to express a bit of activates anymore on
the other hand this middle contig
consisting of a dialogue space and three
of these red genes amino hydrolase
import pump and nowadays those are still
highly expressed in the presence of
benzoyl Dennis Pollock acid and of
course the entire that LCD cast in
Taiwan also remains equally highly
expressed with benzyl penisula Cassidy
compared to glucose as it did with
penicillin pricks glucose well in
sixteen again is that means they looked
at crows on phenylacetic acid compared
to glucose now that then those beta
lactam aces are both down regulated but
so are the amma days MF s calm and emma
days called co2 and the fasten for one
year in the little corner those are all
now significantly down regulated but the
fantasy the acid could have on is still
fully expressed so this kind of against
adjust there's this stepwise metabolism
going on way of a beta lactamase leading
to these
EMA dayses which potentially i'll
hydrolyzing that penicillin to
metabolize including he tells me that
gasps did we shouldn't mental state
aghast at a blog arouse with essential
tribalism and so the question at this
point that as asking was what are these
put one good to an MS enzymes do we and
so i called these the operon for
penicillin utilization so the first
dozen screen
what are these enzymes for the issues
responsible for and verified their
importance was to make some bounce maybe
co southern so we made two different
seven straight knockouts the first one
who shall be represented by B'Elanna we
knocked out the entire click and then
the second knocked out we knocked out
this Jane calls PAF in the phenylacetic
acid attack along this gene encodes it
been find that essentially the first act
and the phenylacetic acid kind of all
Kathleen so allow that enzyme the
bacteria should no longer be able to
grow they'll see the Gaston so first
experimented was verified these strains
still grew well on your normal
conditions so if glucose has a carbon
source and we see the staff is that yeah
these knockouts aren't affecting the
strains metabolism generally the
steadily grow just as both wild-type and
then as expected the PAF knock out the
phenylacetic acid knock out can you only
grow will see the casted business full
carbon source as shown by the red light
here there's no growth interestingly and
maybe not unexpectedly the food operon
knockout is able to grow just as well as
wild type of penalty acid so there's no
downstream effects and that's not
dependence on that path which that's
useful to know so the real interesting
results came when we tried to grow these
trains on penicillin or benzylic acid
and while wild hi baby seal seven days
and will grow using either of those
carbon sources in this case neither
knockout was able to grow over these
conditions she demonstrates that the
Kunar on and the thoughts of traffic in
Tamil
are both necessary for the growth of
baby seals seven on penicillin and
penicillin might compounds so the next
next step that I took was the try to
nail down what exactly are these foot
bar on genes responsible for and so I
focused for now on the on the foot one
gene and the way I without studying that
was I expressed it heterologous Leonie
coli and purify the ends line
to study in vitro I assure you here is
what we are but I predicted the reaction
would be that it takes penicillin or
bezel pistol casted and liberate that'll
send acid from that ally that he'll soon
cast it to go to Central metabolism by a
acetic acid metabolite when this first
craft is my attempts to measure the
itchiness Menten kinetics of this
reaction and so the blue lines represent
my positive controls and when measuring
is hydraulic system anti bond here and
so you can see that the dotted line who
control of course wants to get elastin a
sends line it shows really good
Michaelis Menten kinetics and that's one
of the inspectors you know tomato black
spaces are great like leaving the amide
bond the beta-lactam ring of penicillin
but my other positive controls this
enzyme called penicillin Hema days as
enzymes interesting because it's
actually used industrially to remove
phenylacetic acid from penicillin in
order to make some I synthetic in
Lausanne pencil you can actually remove
that that acetic acid and put on
modified slide chains to get things like
ampicillin or amoxicillin
as those of parfaits mimic effectively
I'm looking for him it's key again that
it has very good kinetics we have
penicillin as a substrate on the other
hand put one was just showing that red
line looks essentially identical to the
no enzyme controlled experiment which
released indicating that could one does
not have much activity if any with
pedestals of substrate I suppose will be
using because we thought that we have a
really good hypothesis to put into this
experiment that really supported this
idea about poop wonder acts truth they
don't see any gases penicillin always
thought about some more it actually
makes a lot more sense
it should remove the phenylacetic acid
group from benzyl penicillin acid and
that's because penicillin which is toxic
to the cells is most likely almost
immediately detoxify by
Elisa's and so the one might not even
see any Elsa I only see Ben's openness
folic acid as a substrate and that's
what I'm showing you the second set of
kinetics experiments so here there's no
big last time ring anymore because we
using pens open scholastic and so but
being allowed to basic controls no
longer have control that shows no
activity but this pedestal amma base in
the small blue line still shows some
decent activity but what's really tiny
is in red as that one enzyme is now
showing good activity using pencil
pencil accounts of substrate so it
really doesn't cures people to break at
my bond and just to confirm this i use
quantitative liquid chromatography
couples in mass spectrometry to measure
the degradation of benzyl pennisula
casted a reactions containing put one or
pedestal emanates or no enzyme has
control and you can see especially at
the long time points that in red coat
one is essential to remove essentially
all or degrade all the beds with nestle
acid in the sample so much greater
extent than penicillin hamid ace so it's
really indicates that put one is having
this activity of releasing phenylacetic
acid from benzyl tennis folic acid so i
started out with a hypothesis that that
was would flow through resistance and
then retro biosynthetic hydrolase back
to me and actually supported by what we
found out here and we can ask sequencing
data and growth data and feature data
that penicillin is detoxify first by
beta lactamase to make friends with
henna slow fasted and then puts one and
possibly put two which i didn't test is
able to use that benzoic acid as a
substrate and remove and we'll see the
castle submit then pedals to the gasket
is sent to the central metabolism by on
the phenylacetic acid can tab along so i
think we bought really good evidence for
that but the last experiment
to do to really nail home the viability
of this strategy for bacteria was to say
now we have this pathway now that we
think is sufficient to allow bacteria
these ABC strain see pest alone can we
put that in the coli for example as a
proof of principle and make that eco
into an antibiotic tantalizer as well so
one thing that we need is the fallacy
fallacy the gases in tackle on there's
actually a more obscure strain of e.coli
called e.coli MW which has a fully
functional than acetic acid the tattle
on what I did was I took that strain and
I transformed it was a vector containing
the beta lactamase which is another
important component as Robin catabolism
and ABC strains and I also have that
rube actor expressed the gene for the
penicillin Emma dace that industrial
enzymes I should be earlier that's
really good at removing phenylacetic
acid for penicillin
so the strain in theory has all three
components are needed we asked about our
Anna so neater and indeed that's what I
saw when I grew it in minimal medium
with penicillin as a sole carbon source
available I see those things or padding
where as you increase the concentration
of penicillin going to darker darker
shades of blue I saw higher and better
growth of this equal I strain now in
contrast than greyscale are the data
points for a ploy strain that is has all
three component by his tunic splits that
has a battle-axe base and the phenol
skating gasket Abelar but it does not
have a madhi's
and so that strains liable growth
penicillin similarly if I express the
blue top wrong instead of penicillin
Hammad ace I again see that that is
sufficient along with the penalty dick
acid I can't add warm to allow equalize
to grow better when using benzyl tennis
folic acid as its carbon source so just
summarize time what we learned in these
experiments it seems that this is the
approach Navy SEAL seven uses the
penicillin
we hypothesized that Paris woman enters
the cell normally through pores like it
does from the other types of bacteria
and once it's in the periplasm it's met
by a secreted beta lactamase which come
first it detoxifies it to pencil finesse
colic acid now we actually aren't sure
how pencil pencil ik acid gets this kind
of plasma which is where it needs to be
because put one of the two don't are
predicted to have a secretion signal so
there might be status colic Nadine's get
into this very much but the protocol
does include this gene and I stated as
an amethyst MF s import pump and so what
I policies that we have is that this
might function to allow benzyl penisula
cast across the membrane to the sinus
wall where it can be used as a substrate
by could born to produce phenylacetic
acid which can go into seneschal
metabolism so on contrast is a little
bit with the engineer d coli string that
i produce and in this case pencil
mammatus is actually also secretes with
a paralyzed M so when penicillin visit
the periplasm it can be directly
converted to that acetic acid plus the
male accent ring by pennisula Matisse or
it can be detoxified by a beta lactamase
to benzyl penicillin acid fog which the
big acid can also be removed by
pennisula nominees and the way that gets
into these finalists all were used in
special metabolism is that the
phenylacetic acid tableau actually
doesn't code a that acetic acid in our
membrane importer so to kind of wrap
things up what I want people to take
away from this talk is that you know we
know that antibiotic resistance there's
like resistance genes are rife in the
soil environment however most of these
loyal bacteria contained resistance
chains that are not strong candidates
for horizontal gene transfer
immobilization the nodal
section of course are these timely
multidrug-resistant produ bacteria which
do in fact have highly globalized
bullet-resistant students these bacteria
are particularly interesting because
many of them are not only resistant to
antibiotics they also could catalyze
them and I hypothesize that catabolism
of these antibiotics proceeds through
detoxification or hydrolysis and we show
that anime PCO 7 this is the case and so
that kind of answers that first major
question I want to ask this project
which is Laura the pathway the enzyme to
use the other question I asked was are
these enzymes or professional antibiotic
pebbles and enzymes are they enzymes of
other functions that are named in this
capacity and the results we found
suggest that isn't mixture of that of
course have a beta lactamase is the
first step and that is a professional in
static resistance enzyme and then the
penalty in acid pathway is also
important for that and those are again
professionally used in that capacity by
the bacteria now linking those two are
these put 1 foot 2 enzymes which seem
like they are probably enzymes that have
mysterious activity and are more mining
in this role and so on obviously
directions that way I take this is a
signal does this general strategy of
detoxification
followed by hydrolysis for other
antibiotics that bacteria can beat and
so example that might be the amino
glycosides
which are largely composed of reliance
subunits and so with that I'd like to
make sure that once that thing every one
of the doctors Lau who did this research
earlier I'm where I did my own research
as well as a one-way from the lab and
our collaborators and then also
acknowledged by 20 sources for my times
of post lock-in the Dom tostão NIH and
with that I'll take any questions thank
you dr. Klass with that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most common
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question drop-down box located on the
far left of your screen tack the
question into the box and click the send
button our speaker will follow up with
your questions you know so let's take a
look at our viewers questions dr.
Crockett the ABC strains actually
cannibalize antibiotics in the
environment so right this is the
question that I've gotten a few other
times and it's a sort of a hand wavy
answer unfortunately so as you might
imagine there aren't piles of penicillin
Sidney of the soil for bacteria to eat
so there's not gonna be bacteria in the
environment that are subsisting slowly
on penicillin although there are some
rivers that are contaminated by a
pharmaceutical runoff out of it don't
have very high levels of mountebanks
another antimicrobials that being said
you know a lot of bacteria are able to
glucose even though there aren't large
blocks of glucose in the soil so I think
what's might be happening is these
bacteria are subsisting on other
components of the soil that are likely
aromatic fatty acids so things that look
like phenylacetic acid and penicillin
and benzyl that is little casted both
kind of fit into that molecular class so
all this happening is the bacteria are
subsisting on these other compounds but
when a one instant penicillin in the
soil they're able to get damage to the
bass as part of a carbon source and then
will be grow them in other laboratory
conditions and for since use pedestal
and I saw so low current source
they are also that cast because they
have these enzymes which have this sort
of cross activity thank you for that um
can we use these phenotypes to fight
antibiotic resistance so I think one of
the cool things about these results is
this idea that we can engineering
bacteria including coli to
catabolized antibiotics like I said a
minute ago there are certain places
where wastewater from pharmaceutical
manufacturing plants are heavily
contaminated with as microbials
including a variety of antibiotics and
at the moment because those waste waters
aren't the in process certain enough
those kinds of microbials are going out
into the environment where they can last
for resistance in bacteria that come in
contact with so one aspect of this
research is that you know we now have a
principle that we can maybe coli into
against about eating strains there might
be potentially used for that where it
can be used to bio remediates
antibiotics that are spilled into the
environments kind of lower their levels
now of course you don't want to be any
more in static resistance genes in these
kinds of allocators environments but as
a proof of concept in terms of
engineering this could be a potential
strategy for paying off those waste
waters for example thank you and doctor
crop is catabolism always connected to
resistance right so it was the thing I
said the idea that an ADC o7m
illustrates we saw we observed that the
food operon includes both these and
moniece's and amino hydrolases as well
as a beta lactamase and so the case with
ABC l7 these those genes are physically
linked they're next to each other but
then also good one can't use an assumed
as a substrate it needs the beta
lactamase to act on stream of it to
convert penicillin into Ben's openness
folic acid so it's functionally
connected also so in that case
resistance and catabolism are
intertwined and can't really be
separated now that might not always be
the case per se so if a bacteria has an
intrinsic
resistance would antibiotic by Lackey
that's harder than static for example
then you might be able to get catabolism
without needing to have and that's about
resistance chain in place thank you for
that we have one more question what
happens to the other parts of the
penicillin molecule right so in these
experiments you know we zoomed in on the
phenylacetic acid group of penicillin as
being the important part metabolism but
that's just about half the molecule so
you have the Felicita gas you also have
the middle Aksum group that squeezed by
they'll activation and then essentially
just thrown away so we have the loots
passed maybe Co 7 and the other
antibiotics and tablets and strains just
see if they're able to use the
beta-lactam ring as a carbon source once
you remove the pellissippi acid group
from penicillin and as far as we get
Salamone the bacteria able to grow using
that so it seems like the bacteria are
in just moving at elevated acids needs
and then thrown away the rest of the
molecule thank you and dr. Kraft thank
you so much for today's presentation and
for your important research I'd also
like to take their time to think lab
routes for making sure these
educationally liked as possible before
we go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast is available for
on-demand viewing until December 2018
then receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share the
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now and thanks for joining us we
hope to see you again something I do